hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well our culture is
become variable the way moral
disagreement tends to break down is one
way what are you going to identify its
characters in our society is another way
and one of the things that he says about
emotivism
from a social perspective is that it
destroys the distinction between
manipulative and not manipulative types
of social relations
so it turns everybody not necessarily to
a manipulator all the time it's somebody
who can't see any real difference
between not manipulating people treating
them as if they have something like
inherent dignity or worth and
manipulating people seeing that as just
means to an end to something like that
sometimes even seen themselves that way
so if the motive is omits into a culture
and MacIntyre thinks that he has an IRS
that's one of the things that happens
what it's calling characters are certain
social roles and so let's talk we have
all sorts of different social roles yeah
and what do we mean by that I'm
occupying one social role right now just
talking to you up here in front of the
stage you know about some stuff that I
put an I learn for you that I went to
school and got a PhD in a PhD you get
the Indian right you guys are occupying
a social role by your behavior here
right now is this the only social role
that you have the only social role that
I have I'm a father I'm a husband a son
those are familiar but those are also
solo roles right if I don't send my kids
anything on their birthday my good dad
or bad dad so people are like whispering
go ahead and say what are you talking
about here that that's something that
kids anything either birthday yeah
that's okay there's other things that go
into being a good dad besides that but
there's a social role and we can we can
say people are fulfilling their social
roles well or not and do you have a lot
of social roles and you have a job
there's a social role right if you're a
waiter
what job do you guys have let's say
you're a waiter you're coming to the
table there's certain expectations of
you there are certain expectations you
have of the other people there these
government reactions they make things
intelligible McIntyre sells and you
don't actually have to buy into your
social necessarily you could be just
like putting it on or being kind of
doubts about it uses the example for
example of a Catholic priest or a union
leader they see the things that they're
supposed to say but they don't really
believe you know the Catholic priest has
lost the faith or the union leader
really hates working people and would
like to sell them out if he could but
anybody doesn't so there's certain
certain social roles where a personality
could be different there are certain
social roles McIntyre says that type
personality they're certain yeah certain
social roles where the personality is
tied in with them where if you're having
this kind of social role in your there's
really a lot of pressure to conform
yourself to it you have a certain kind
of moral expectation to value things in
a certain way and he talks about three
maybe there could be more in modern
culture
and a therapist now that doesn't mean
that every time that you get involved
with management you're necessarily the
manager yeah that doesn't mean that if
you go and see a therapist they're a bad
person they're both honest that's not
necessarily so right but there is
something about these particular rules
the in Madeira and the MacIntyre things
that tie it but let's talk about this
for a second a state never called
anybody a testing oh you and you're in
such an aesthete it always have to be
one that term what what do you think
this means yeah yeah I put that it's
essentially being like yeah I guess the
rigidity but we don't actually have to
be rich in our society to the bill helps
to be rich because that takes your mind
off a lot of things what does it mean to
be in this
yeah kinda like materialistic oh no well
in face value not necessarily I mean
there are certain ways in which you
could do it where you might be very
materialistic what what are the word
mean you think of it has some sort of
connection aesthetics yeah no no no what
is this tax yeah Tessa booth Beauty
there's a philosophical this when it's
like you know conservative what is
beauty when is ours
what is this applying now I'll think
about the kind of evaluation that goes
into assessing something and it's
beautiful or let's use some other
systemic categories that we actually use
in our own time something is cool
that's an aesthetic category something
is this stupid when you contrast cool
and stupid you're not actually say
something relaxed intelligence if you
call an album stupid you're not actually
saying that the album is stupid right
you're saying it's aesthetically
unpleasing somebody aren't you
relax certain aesthetic characteristics
what are the sort of things that you
might say this about works apart right
how many of you go to the museum
is that how you is that your aesthetic
experience that you're making judgments
about most of the time okay that's an
important one
Maris is nice it's got quite you I
remember the last place that I worked I
didn't realize how ugly it was until
they had a friend come that I want to
give this friend a tour and I thought
there would be a nice place on campus to
tame though and I realize that single
base view yeah so it was aesthetically
amazing yes yes all those glossy
magazines that are filled with ads
people actually put those ads together
and they got paid a good amount of money
to put those hands together in
aesthetically pleasing ways and
therefore the products that may or may
not be aesthetically pleasing ultimately
you know probably put the product on and
it's a clause or something like that it
actually looks good it's perfume
hopefully it actually smells it smells
different in the magazine that it's
gonna smell on here on your body right
what else do we get all the stag
attractiveness of people food food is
very much about snacks now can you look
at the whole world in terms of just
everything being an aesthetic phenomena
everything being there just for
enjoyment for consumption or maybe
talking about or tweeting about or
facebooking about now Pinterest right
Pinterest is a static medium by advanced
very nature are other people who live
their whole lives the answer to submerge
moral judgment into just aesthetic
judgment that would be the richest eat
they're worried more about whether
something is cool then whether it's good
as a matter of fact they don't even
worry about whether it's good or bad
those are not categories after a while
that makes sense to them
and if a motive ism is right why
wouldn't why wouldn't that make sense if
good and bad is just how we feel about
stuff how is that any different than I
like cake you like pie I like you know
trip scampi and you like some other
shrimp dish it's all I like this music
you like that music that is a type that
there's McIntyre says it fits into this
emotivist
let's look at the other two there is
they're even more interesting manager
what's going on in bureaucratic
organizations in groups where you have
to allocate resources doesn't every
company of a mission statement merit
actually has a mission statement how
many of you looked at the mission
statement
good portion particularly meaningful it
is that's a new mission statement values
that are supposed to be difficult come
in close minded we're going to fix that
right lot of mission statements nobody
pays much attention to that why I mean
isn't it pretty important I mean hold
the whole to deliver a quality product
to the consumer yeah you know a good
price that could apply to so many
different ones and those are values
right those are primarily values of
efficiency there are companies who say
they want to change the world things but
you know you could be involved in those
organizations and not care about that at
all it could be like so concerned with
okay what are my goals how am I going to
accomplish them what are my resources
how am I going to as McIntyre says how
am I going to connect means to these ads
then you never think about the ends you
know I mean it's interesting I'm not I'm
not actually knocking war or fighting
for things like that myself right now
but there are a lot of people who worked
at companies
so we outsource a lot of the stuff that
produce munitions or boggers or missiles
or things like that and it didn't matter
them at all
now what they were producing were
instruments and they might have actually
been you know people who personally they
felt that were as a bad thing or you
know American you know the current
regime or whatever but they don't focus
on because what their job is to do is to
make everything run properly and so
questions of rain wrong can't really be
dealt with because those are a matter of
individual values those are subjective
so we have to push those out of the
process what can you notice on
efficiency doing the most with the
resources that you have that becomes the
primary goal and that's the only part
where they're being rational everything
else is just emotivist for the therapist
what the McIntyre says whether the
manager does you're the life of
organizations the therapist does with
respect to how you know personal well
adjustment those sorts of things getting
us over
use psychology teamwork our neuroses now
we talk in terms of disorders since the
DSM my DSM for there's an ED site people
and there are recognition that before we
change to disorders Thank You Rosa
yeah the therapists like McIntyre says
is not primarily concerned with truth
they're concerned with making people
feel better happier you know fit in
better with other people that's the
primary goal and you can do that well
thinking that value judgments are almost
purely subjective just you know
expressions of our emotions or
preferences that would actually make you
a pretty good therapist wouldn't it you
wouldn't be bothered by all these sort
of worries about whether you're actually
steering people in the wrong way so long
as you can figure out how to get rid of
their disorders and make them fit in
better according to certain you know
expert criteria that you can find in the
diagnostic Statistical
you're doing the right thing so with the
the manager and the therapist worries
about ultimate ends and whether they're
actually good ends or not for rid of
those just focus on the process with the
rich St you don't even have that you
just have I'm just going to focus on
whatever makes me feel good these are
all types of emotivist characters these
are ways in which people you might say
structure their lives and their
activities and these define the ways in
which we interact with each other in our
culture quite a bit like I said with
those with the drug addict if you're a
drug addict and you get into a treatment
program and you want to get better
they don't care why you want to get
better there's interested in getting you
better by certain criteria they don't
care whether that effects all these
other things there as long as they can
reproduce you eventually as somebody
who's cured that's fine noticed too that
the same things could be tied in with
say the same organization some people
adopt social causes almost like rich
estates they just want to get involved
with something that makes them feel kind
of good and
attributing something and making a
difference but they never actually worry
about whether it's really good or bad
the closet they're tight it they just
want to have something that would be
that would be this at the same time
who makes the quasi actually work you
could have some manager who you know is
not interested in that cause whatsoever
they're just interested in making those
dollars that are contributed actually
funneled to the right things you know
trying to distribute this is a really
broad